[Music] In Korean
medicine, it is said that many diseases come from the heart, but I think that a really delicious
cup of crab tree is very helpful in relieving stress, so it
has a very positive effect mentally.
[Music]
My name is Kim Hee.
I have lived in Seoul in Korea all the time.
I started a crack TV company called The Booth 4 years ago
and now I am working as a creative director.
Now I
was like this as a director at a local clinic
[Music]
Uh, the variety of beer is sure to understand. The quantitative background
was very helpful, and
in summer last year, I put a ring finger called Maekmundong, the ventilation volume,
to protect the road now in the summer.  I also made beer that can do it. I
have an excessive eye for beer. I think it's Korean medicine and science. Uh, I
've experienced it now, but my boyfriend and a single reporter
made it at 3 o'clock.
We all think that Korean beer is very tasteless.
[Music]
I think it was only 5 years ago that
Koreans didn't know that there are different flavors of beer.
It was very small, but it spreads quickly and is growing as a culture overall
[Music]